in just four weeks the number of
coronavirus cases
in children soared 90 percent in the u.s
the american academy of pediatrics
reports almost
180 000 new cases in kids
between july 9th and august 6th based on
data from states
more than 380 thousand covid 19 cases in
children
have been reported in this country since
the pandemic began
senior medical correspondent dr tara
narula joins us now tara good morning
what does the data say about how the
virus affects
kids well anthony you know parents are
really struggling with what to do
particularly when it comes to schools
and so we need to give them a realistic
understanding
of what the data and the science says
and for now the understanding is that
overwhelmingly
kids tend to be affected less severely
there are low rates of hospitalization
for kids
and when you look at the states in new
york city that reported mortality data
kids have accounted for about zero to
0.4
of the covid deaths in those that
reported now it's important to
say that when we hear words like kids
are immune
those words matter and words like immune
are misleading
and inaccurate when you think about the
fact that nine percent of all the
coveted cases in this country
are in kids that kids have been
hospitalized
and the 86 children that have died to
hear
those words that kids are immune is
extremely disheartening for those
parents that have suffered those losses
tara what's behind this recent surge in
cases in kids
well certainly anthony we're doing a lot
more testing now than we were in the
beginning
so we are going to pick up on more kids
we're now testing not just the sickest
of the sick
we're testing kids who may be mildly
symptomatic
but also the data is really generated
from the states
and so it depends on how the states are
reporting the data what they're
releasing publicly what format they're
reporting that data in
and even how they classify child cases
varies from state to state some states
say
it's 0 to 14 other states say it's 0 to
24. so
we're really getting an emerging but
incomplete picture
of what this looks like for children in
this country you
you mentioned the issue of kids going
back to school it's something
millions of parents are confronting
right now what does this tell us about
the safety of classrooms
well i think first of all there's no
question it's polarizing and we've seen
success stories both internationally and
even in this country when you look at
certain day care centers and camps
we've also seen failures but in general
i think that schools can reopen
in certain places safely and i think
most public health officials will tell
you the priorities should be to open
schools but it really depends on three
things
first of all the infection rate the
community transmission rate in that
area of the school has to be low the
school itself
has to make sure that they're putting
into place really strong precautions
like
having kids in small pods social
distancing masks
good ventilation isolation and testing
and tracing
and then finally families really have to
look at who their
child is are is their child more
vulnerable do they have an underlying
health condition is someone in their
family more vulnerable
and then when we talk about teachers too
we need to make sure that we
are calling them frontline workers and
providing them with things like ppe
but i think it can be done in the right
setting in the right places
but there's not a one-size-fits-all
approach for every part of the country
dr taran arula thank you very much